ROLE IN SUPPORTING THE TURKISH
GOVERNMENT.
THEY DID NOT RESPOND AS THEY
HAVE NOT RESPONDED FOREARM AND A
REQUEST, BUT WE ARE GOING TO
KEEP TRYING.
THE ACADEMY HAS LEANED LEFT FOR
A LONG TIME BUT MANY SCHOOLS
THAT TILT IS BECOMING
MONOLITHIC, UTTERLY MONOLITHIC.
A NEW REPORT LOOKS AT THE
FACULTY AT MORE THAN 50 TOP
LIBERAL ARTS COLLEGES AND FOUND
THAT IF THE SERVICE ACADEMIES
ARE EXCLUDED, AIR FORCE, NAVY,
ARMY, REGISTERED DEMOCRATS
OUTNUMBER REGISTERED REPUBLICANS
MORE THAN 12-1.
MUCH MORE THAN THAT ON SOME
CAMPUSES.
THIS LACK OF IDEOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY IS BREEDING ARROGANCE
AMONG OTHER THINGS, SAISON.
GERARD ALEXANDER IS A POLITICAL
SCIENCE WERE PRESSURE,
PROFESSOR.
HE WROTE A GREAT PIECE FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OVER THE
WEEKEND, MORNING LIBERALS WERE
NOT AS SMART AS YOU THINK.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT DO YOU MEAN
BY THAT, LIBERALS, YOU ARE NOT
AS SMART AS YOU THINK YOU MIGHT
>> AS EVERY WRITER KNOWS, THEY
DON'T CHOOSE THEIR OWN TITLES
AND I MIGHT HAVE PREFERRED
SOMETHING A LITTLE LESS LIKE
CLICKBAIT OR AGGRESSIVE AND I
WAS TRYING TO COMMUNICATE TO
LIBERALS, MANY OF WHOM I THINK
MEAN WELL THE COUNTRY AND DON'T
REALIZE THE EFFECTS THEY ARE
HAVING THAT THEIR TONE, THEIR
APPROACH TO A LOT OF OUR
NATIONAL CONVERSATIONS ABOUT A
WHOLE SLEW OF ISSUES, IT CAN
ATTRACT AND PERSUADE PEOPLE
GIVING A SPEECH FROM AN    FROMA
STAGE, USING ALL KINDS OF THE
PLATFORMS THEY HAVE AN AMERICAN
LIFE, THE PROMINENCE THEY HAVE
AN AMERICAN LIFE, THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN I CAN BE USED TO SET
AN EXAMPLE TO EDUCATE, TO
ATTRACT, TO LEND CELEBRITY AND
CREDIBILITY TO POINTS OF VIEW,
BUT IT'S DISTRESSING TO ME HOW
OFTEN THOSE PLATFORMS END UP
BEING USED IN WAYS THAT
COMMUNICATE SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS,
A TONE OF INTELLECTUAL AND MORAL
SUPERIORITY.
HOW OFTEN THEY ARE USED TO BE
RATE INSTEAD OF PERSUADE AND I
THINK ONE OF THE EFFECTS
LIBERALS DON'T REALIZE THEY ARE
HAVING IS HOW MUCH THEY ARE
ALIENATING OTHER PEOPLE.
I THINK IT'S ALMOST ENTIRELY
INADVERTENT AND I THINK IT'S ONE
OF MANY TRENDS IN AMERICAN LIFE
THAT'S REALLY UNHELPFUL THAT WE
COULD BETTER AVOID AND I TRY TO
GIVE ANY ARTICLE AN IDEA OF WAYS
THEY MIGHT TRY TO AVOID DOING
THAT.
>> Tucker: DIVERSITY WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE GUARD RAIL
THAT PREVENTED PEOPLE FROM GOING
OFF ENTER SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS AND
LACK OF SELF-AWARENESS.
HAVING PEOPLE AROUND WHO
DISAGREE WITH YOU AND BRING
DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCES TO
THE CONVERSATION WAS SUPPOSED TO
BROADEN US.
IF IN MOST UNIVERSITIES THERE IS
NOBODY WHO DOESN'T AGREE WITH
YOU, YOU NEVER MEET ANYBODY WITH
A DIFFERENT VIEW, WHY WOULDN'T
YOU BECOME ARROGANT AND DUMB
OVER TIME AS THEY HAVE?
>> IT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
LIBERALS HAVE BEEN SUCH GREAT
FORCES IN MODERN AMERICAN LIFE
OR BRINGING CERTAIN KINDS OF
DIVERSITY TO THE TABLE AND BEING
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THAT.
WHO DOESN'T THINK AMERICA HAS
BENEFITED FROM MORE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN FACES, MORE
HISPANIC VOICES, MORE WOMEN IN
PROMINENT POSITIONS, AMERICA HAS
BEEN OFFENDED INTELLECTUALLY AND
OTHERWISE FROM THAT BUT THEY
REALLY HAVE HAD A BLIND SPOT
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT SOME
PEOPLE I ADMIRE GREATLY HAVE
STARTED CALLING VIEWPOINT
DIVERSITY, MAY BE BETTER THAN
IDEOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND,
WHAT'S THE POINT OF ETHNIC OR
GENDER DIVERSITY IF NOT TO BRING
VIEWPOINT DIVERSITY?
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE POINT.
HOW CAN -- IN OTHER WORDS, IF
YOU HAVE A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
ALL LOOKED DIFFERENT BUT COME
FROM THE SAME CULTURE AND HAVE
THE SAME VIEWS, HOW WAS THAT IN
ANY SENSE DIVERSE?
>> ORIGINALLY THEY DIDN'T COME
FROM THE SAME VIEWPOINTS.
PEOPLE WHO CAME FROM THE
JIM CROW SOUTH HAD VERY
DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCES THAN
UPPER-MIDDLE-CLASS NORTHERNERS.
BUT INCREASINGLY WHAT HAS
HAPPENED, ESPECIALLY THROUGH
AMERICAN UNIVERSITIES IS A TREND
TOWARDS GENDER AND ETHNIC
DIVERSITY, RACIAL DIVERSITY, BUT
NOT INTELLECTUAL DIVERSITY.
I THINK THAT HAS BEEN REALLY
COSTLY AND JUST SOME OF THE WAYS
YOU ARE SUGGESTING.
IT BREEDS, AMONG OTHER THINGS,
INCREDIBLE INTELLECTUAL
COMPLACENCY AND I THINK THAT IN
A SENSE, VIEWPOINTS THAT
CONSERVATIVES MIGHT BOYS COME
UNDER TREMENDOUS CRITICAL
SCRUTINY, ARE REALLY A QUESTION
OR REALLY RAKED OVER THE COALS
AND OFTEN PRESUMPTIVELY REJECTED
AS ILLEGITIMATE OR UNPERSUASIVE.
WHEREAS A LOT OF ASSUMPTIONS
HELD BY PEOPLE IN THE AMERICAN
LEFT GO UNEXAMINED FOR LONG
PERIODS.
THAT'S THE KIND OF INTELLECTUAL
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH ERROR CAN
THRIVE, IN WHICH ORTHODOXIES CAN
GEL AND IN WHICH, YOU ARE RIGHT,
IN WHICH VIEWPOINTS CAN BE,
INSTEAD OF DIVERSE, THEY CAN END
UP BECOMING HOMOGENIZED.
THERE'S A REAL DANGER THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
NOT IN THE SENSE THAT ALL PEOPLE
IN THE LEFT AGREE WITH EACH
OTHER BECAUSE OUR CAMPUSES THEY
DON'T.
ANY ACADEMIC KNOWS THAT.
BUT ORTHODOXY AND HOMOGENEITY IN
THE SENSE THAT THEY STOP
REFLECTING THE TRUE DIVERSITY
INTELLECTUALLY OF THE WHOLE
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: NICELY PUT.
I'M GLAD THAT YOU ARE IN THAT